>>> TONIGHT, VIGIL'S BEING HELD
IN WAUKESHA, WISCONSIN, AS
RESIDENTS REMEMBER THOSE WHO
DIED AND WERE INJURED WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL DROVE AN SUV THROUGH
AN ANNUAL CHRISTMAS PARADE ON
SUNDAY.
AT LEAST FIVE CONFIRMED DEAD,
DOZENS MORE INJURED.
THE FIRE CHIEF TODAY SAID FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO HAD BEEN IN THE
MILITARY LIKENED IT TO A WAR
ZONE.
OMAR JIMENEZ IS IN WAUKESHA WITH
THE DETAILS, INCLUDING WHAT WE
NOW KNOW ABOUT A SUSPECT IN
CUSTODY.
>> Reporter: A SHOCKED COMMUNITY
LEARNING THE NAMES OF THE
NEIGHBORS THEY LOST.
>> VIRGINIA SORENSON,
79-YEAR-OLD FEMALE.
LEANNA ONES, 71-YEAR-OLD FEMALE.
TAMARA DURAND, 52-YEAR-OLD
FEMALE.
JAMES, 52-YEAR-OLD FEMALE.
WILHELM HASPEL, 81-YEAR-OLD
MALE.
>>> RANGING IN AGE FROM 52 TO 81
YEARS OLD.
>> PEOPLE DOWN IN THE STREET!
CASUALTIES ON MAIN STREET.
>> Reporter: ALONG WITH THE
DEAD, 48 PEOPLE WERE INJURED.
SOME AS YOUNG AS 3 YEARS OLD.
18 CHILDREN, INCLUDING THREE
SETS OF SIBLINGS, ARE BEING
TREATED AT CHILDREN'S WISCONSIN,
A HOSPITAL IN MILWAUKEE.
>> TWO OF THE 48 ARE CHILDREN
AND THEY ARE IN CRITICAL
CONDITION.
>> INJURIES RANGED FROM FACIAL
ABRASIONS TO BROKEN BONES TO
SERIOUS HEAD INJURIES.
>> Reporter: POLICE IDENTIFIED
THE SUSPECT AS 39-YEAR-OLD
DARRYL BROOKS.
>> THE SUSPECT, PRIOR TO THE
INCIDENT, WAS INVOLVED IN A
DOMESTIC DISTURBANCE.
>> Reporter: BROOKS WAS RELEASED
ON $1,000 BAIL EARLIER THIS
MONTH IN CONNECTION TO CHARGES
INCLUDING DOMESTIC ABUSE.
HE ALLEGEDLY RAN OVER A WOMAN
WITH HIS CAR, AND THE INCIDENT
CAME AFTER ANOTHER 2020 CASE
WHERE HE WAS CHARGED WITH TWO
COUNTS OF RECKLESSLY ENDANGERING
SAFETY.
HE ALLEGEDLY FIRED A GUN DURING
AN ARGUMENT.
CNN REACHED OUT TO HIS ATTORNEY
FROM THE INCIDENTS, BUT DID NOT
GET A RESPONSE.
MEANWHILE, NEW AUDIO OF THE
PARADE INCIDENT MAKES CLEAR THE
CHAOS OF THE MOMENT, HEARD IN
THE VOICES OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS.
>> A RED ESCAPE, BLACK MALE, I
COULDN'T STOP IT.
HE IS GOING WESTBOUND.
BLOWING HIS HORN.
>> Reporter: ALONG THE PARADE
ROUTE, KAYLEIGH THOUGHT AT FIRST
THE VEHICLE WAS IN THE PARADE.
SECONDS LATER, SHE REALIZED IT
WASN'T.
>> YOU SEE PEOPLE RUNNING AROUND
AND SCREAMING AND CRYING AND
RUNNING INTO THE STOREFRONTS.
UM, AND YOU REALIZE THAT LIKE
THIS IS REAL.
THIS IS SERIOUS.
AND PEOPLE ARE HURT BECAUSE OF
IT.
>> Reporter: AMONG THOSE DEAD,
MEMBERS OF MILWAUKEE'S DANCING
GRANNIES.
THE POST TO THEIR FACEBOOK PAGE
SAID THOSE WHO DIED WERE
EXTREMELY PASSIONATE GRANNIES.
THEIR EYES GLEAMED WITH THE JOY
OF BEING A GRANNY.
THEY WERE THE GLUE THAT HELD US
TOGETHER.
NOW, AS THE COMMUNITY HERE TRIES
TO RECOVER THE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE SUSPECT, DARRYL BROOKS,
CONTINUES.
HE HAS A CRIMINAL HISTORY GOING
BACK TO THE '90s BUT ON THAT
INCIDENT HE POSTED A THOUSAND
DOLLARS BAIL FOR, THE WOMAN HE
ALLEGEDLY RAN OVER CLAIMED TO BE
THE MOTHER OF HIS CHILD AND ALSO
CLAIMED THAT THAT CAR PART OF IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN UNTIL AFTER HE
ALLEGEDLY HIT HER WITH A CLOSED
FIST.
NOW, THE MILWAUKEE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE SAID
THAT BAIL AMOUNT SET WAS
INAPPROPRIATELY LOW AND IS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH THEIR
RISK-ASSESSMENT PROCEDURE.
AND IT IS WHY THEY ARE NOW
LAUNCHING AN INTERNAL REVIEW.
ON THIS CHRISTMAS-PARADE
INCIDENT, THE SUSPECT HAS HIS
INITIAL COURT APPEARANCE
SCHEDULED FOR TOMORROW WHERE
POLICE HAVE SAID THEY WOULD BE
REFERRING FIVE COUNTS OF
FIRST-DEGREE INTENTIONAL
HOMICIDE.
JOHN.
>> OMAR JIMENEZ, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>>> OUR NEXT GUEST, NOT ONLY WAS
THERE YESTERDAY AND WITNESSED
THE VIOLENCE.
HE HAD TWO CHILDREN MARCHING IN
THE PARADE.
ONE OF THOSE CHILDREN, AS YOU
SEE SPOTLIGHTED HERE, NEARLY HIT
BY THE SUV AS IT WENT THROUGH
THE CROWD.
I AM JOINED NOW BY KELLY DAVIS.
KELLY, THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US.
I'M SO SORRY IT'S UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
HOW ARE YOU AND YOUR FAMILY
HOLDING UP TONIGHT?
>> WE'RE -- WE'RE STILL IN
SHOCK.
YOU KNOW, IT -- IT WAS AN
UNFORTUNATE INCIDENT, NOT
SOMETHING YOU WOULD EVER EXPECT
TO HAPPEN, ESPECIALLY AT A
HOLIDAY PARADE.
I KNOW MY TWO CHILDREN THERE
WERE IN THE PARADE WERE JUST
REALLY SHAKEN UP LAST NIGHT.
YOU KNOW, FROM SEEING A LOT OF
THEIR FRIENDS, THEIR BAND MATES,
YOU KNOW, BE HURT IN SUCH A
HORRIFIC FASHION.
AND IT -- YOU KNOW, IT -- IT'S
TAKEN A LOT WITH THEM TO TRY AND
REALLY GRASP WHAT -- WHAT
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST 24 OR 36
HOURS HERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WALK US THROUGH WHERE YOU WERE
ON THE ROUTE, AND WHEN YOU
NOTICED SOMETHING WAS GOING
WRONG.
>> I WAS SITTING WITH ONE OF MY
OTHER SONS AND WE WERE ON MAIN
STREET RIGHT AROUND EAST AVENUE.
AND THAT'S WHEN WE SAW THE CAR,
FIRST, COMING THROUGH.
UM, AND THE CAR WASN'T GOING
THAT FAST, AT FIRST.
BUT WHEN WE NOTICED THE CAR, IT
WAS LIKE, WAIT A MINUTE.
WHAT IS THIS -- WHAT IS THIS
PERSON DOING?
THAT -- IT'S -- SOMETHING'S NOT
RIGHT AND I THOUGHT MAYBE THEY
WERE TRYING TO GET TO THE
APARTMENT BUILDINGS THAT WERE ON
THE -- ACROSS THE STREET FROM
US.
WELL, AS THEY STARTED TO KEEP
GOING WEST ON MAIN STREET, THEY
STARTED GETTING FASTER AND I'M
LIKE SOMETHING'S NOT RIGHT.
AND THEN, THEY PASSED OVER
BARSTOW STREET OR AVENUE AND
THAT'S WHEN I NOTICED WHEN THE
CAR -- THE RED SUV -- STARTED TO
SWERVE IN AND OUT OF THE PARADE
ROUTE.
>> SOMETHING'S NOT RIGHT.
YEAH.
>> AND AT THAT POINT, YEAH,
SOMETHING'S NOT RIGHT.
AND THEN, I SAW WHAT I THOUGHT
WAS KIND OF LIKE A SKIP.
LIKE, MAYBE, IT HAD HIT A CAR
AND THAT'S WHEN I SAID TO MY SON
WHO I WAS WITH -- I'M LIKE, WE
GOT TO GO.
SOMETHING'S NOT RIGHT.
SO WE TOOK OFF DOWN IN THAT
DIRECTION.
AND BY THE TIME WE GOT DOWN TO
BARSTOW, I MEAN, THERE WERE
PEOPLE RUNNING EVERYWHERE.
UM, SCREAMING.
AND, YOU KNOW, BODIES WERE ON
THE GROUND AT THAT POINT.
AND FOR ME, IT WAS ABOUT TRYING
TO FIND OUT WHERE MY SON AND MY
DAUGHTER WERE.
>> NOW, YOUR DAUGHTER, ISABELLA,
RIGHT?
>> YEAH, ISABEL.
>> ISABEL.
YOU COULDN'T FIND HER.
HOW LONG DID IT TAKE YOU TO FIND
HER?
>> TOOK ABOUT TEN MINUTES TO
FIND HER.
UM, I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH, AS
WE WERE GETTING CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO THE ACCIDENT SCENE,
UM, I RAN ACROSS PHILLIP WHO YOU
HIGHLIGHTED EARLIER AND HE WAS
WITH A COUPLE OTHER OF HIS BAND
MATES.
AND I JUST TOLD HIM, LOOK, YOU
GOT TO GET OUT OF THIS.
HURRY UP BECAUSE IT'S NOT SAFE
RIGHT NOW.
GO WITH YOUR FRIENDS, FIND
SOMEWHERE SAFE AND WE WILL FIND
YOU.
AND THEN, THAT'S WHEN MY SON AND
I START TED TO SEARCH FOR MY OTR
DAUGHTER.
NOW, DID HAVE MY THIRD SON, MY
OLDEST SON SITTING A LITTLE
FURTHER DOWN ON BUCKLEY AND MAIN
STREET.
AND HE WAS COMING TOWARDS THE
ACCIDENT SCENE TRYING TO SEE IF
HE COULD ALSO FIND HER.
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT WAS
GOING THROUGH YOUR HEAD WHEN YOU
COULDN'T FIND YOUR DAUGHTER.
HOW AWFUL THAT MUST HAVE BEEN.
NOR, CAN I IMAGINE WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO SEE THE VIDEO NOW THAT
WE'VE SHOWN OF HOW CLOSE THE --
THE TRUCK CAME TO PHILLIP.
>> EXACTLY.
YOU KNOW, LATER ON THAT EVENING
WHEN I WAS ABLE TO, YOU KNOW,
ACTUALLY SEE PHILLIP, MET UP
WITH HIM LATER ON THAT EVENING,
IT WAS -- IT WAS VERY DISTURBING
TO SEE HOW CLOSE HE CAME.
>> AND LASTLY, I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE COACHED KIDS WHO WERE HURT.
>> YES.
>> YOUR CHILDREN HAVE FRIENDS
WHO WERE HURT.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THEIR
CONDITION?
>> UM, A COUPLE OF KIDS -- YOU
KNOW, I'VE HEARD THEY'RE IN
STABLE CONDITION.
I KNOW ONE OF THE KIDS, UM, HAD
TO GO THROUGH SURGERY AGAIN
TODAY AND HE HAD SURGERY LAST
NIGHT.
I HEARD HE'S IN STABLE
CONDITION.
UM, SO THAT MADE ME HAPPY TO
HEAR THAT THEY, YOU KNOW, BOTH
WERE IN STABLE CONDITION AND
GETTING BETTER.
IT'S NEVER EASY TO SEE KIDS,
LIKE YOU SAID, WHO YOU'VE
COACHED BEFORE GET INJURED LIKE
THAT.
AND AFTER I FOUND MY DAUGHTER,
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WILL
ALWAYS STICK WITH ME IS, YOU
KNOW, JUST WATCHING AND SEEING,
YOU YOU KNOW, THE BODIES LAYING
IN THE STREET AND THE BLOOD THAT
WAS ALL OVER.
AS MUCH AS I WANTED TO HELP, I
DO HAVE TO SAY THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE, A LOT OF FIRST
RESPONDERS THERE IN THE STREET
HELPING EVERYBODY OUT.
THE COMMUNITY REALLY SEEMED TO
HAVE COME TOGETHER, AND REALLY
HELPED OUT AND IN EVERYBODY'S
TIME OF NEED.
>> KELLY, I AM SO SORRY YOU HAD
TO SEE THAT AND GO THROUGH IT.
I AM SO HAPPY FOR YOU, THAT YOU
AND